you've reached the voicemail of Dwight
Kur Sho please
[Music]
leave
stop
ah I have no feeling in my fingers or
penis but I think it was worth
it um I was laying on the ground
defenseless and uh he just kept throwing
him until he exhausted himself and uh
then how about icing it LOL to
White
Merry Christmas Merry Christmas no why
why did you bring that here don't worry
she's dead oh
wait he's dead why
what I accidentally ran over it it's a
Christmas miracle well get it out of
here relax okay and because this is
Christmas I am going to roast this goose
and prepare it with a wild rice dressing
do we have any cayenne pepper in the
kitchen Merry Christmas TW Jim wow what
do we got here what does it look like
dead goose and circle gets the square
all right so can you watch this I'm
going to get my carving knife out of the
trunk a d we talked about this no Toby
this is different he is already dead
once I brought in a duck to prepare for
lunch and people got
upset apparently they got attached to
the duck and didn't want to see it
killed he was already dead and we shuts
use every part of the goose the meat has
a delicious Smoky rich flavor plus you
can use the molten goose grease and save
it in the refrigerator thus saving you a
trip to the store for a can of expensive
goose grease wow win-win exactly thank
you Jim I like goose and it's already
dead is it so crazy if we eat it that is
crazy that's crazy Dwight you cannot
keep that here okay that is ridiculous
and totally against the spirit of
Christmas come on Dwight we went over
this like for half an hour it's
Christmas
to it's a dead animal in an office can't
I'm
sorry
please
please clean it in your
car I would like it off my desk no Pam
take a chill
pill
go push God push no no no turn around
turn around you're break it break it you
shove it shove it
back here we go don't break the branches
Dwight ah I got a splinter well suck it
up we all have problems hey everybody
look what we
have nice huh I've got it
leveraged straight one one two two
three
Merry
Christmas did it
work well sort
of so this is what every day would be
like if you hadn't left
India
just she
burning we got a live one on
fire
[Music]
all
right all right Angela drafted me into
the party planning committee her Memo
said that we need to prepare for every
possible
disaster which to me
seems excessive no no way it no come on
Mike let me brought a hat for just a
couple hours you want to be Santa yeah
have you ever seen Santa Santa yeah I've
seen Santa who cares well I'm sorry it
just doesn't work Michael I would like
to be the elf that makes sense because
he has elfish
features dick the halls with bows of
[Music]
Hol hey I would like a nice slice of
Christmas Pam side of candy pams and
perhaps some Pam chops can I help you
with
mint got it yeah okay let's go in I'm
freezing people wait wait wait come back
come back one fun one we're going to do
a fun one one Charli's Angels one let's
go okay this is just a Christmas card
from your paper supplier no one's
putting this on their fridge oh I got it
you guys how about this Michael what if
all the boys are on one side all the
girls are on the other the boys are like
why a and the girls are like let's go
shopping let's just jump in the air
that's that's a picture yes jump in the
air we're going to jump in the air here
we go okay one two
three not everyone jumped okay everybody
jump in the air this time please here we
go one two
three still some people not jumping you
got to be kidding me who isn't jumping
I'll tell you who Daryl Phyllis Stanley
Angela and Oscar I am jumping you are
let me see
jump oh my God this is a store-bought
camera this isn't one of those special
military grade cameras that would be
able to capture that I'm freezing um
also Aaron is jumping way too early
she's on the ground by 3 I don't want to
miss it well I if we all jump really
high we'll be in the air longer okay
here's a question nobody's asking is
this worth it don't answer that people
listen up and listen good we need to
just get one picture where we're all in
the air at the same time yes I believe
in us we can do this okay I'm three uh
everyone in the air three two one
zero we didn't get it Stanley no I'm
going to handle the cord okay safety
reasons I know how to plug something in
I want to do it all
right let's count it down like
Rockefeller Center
ready three two
[Applause]
one presents are the best way to show
some someone how much you care it is
like this tangible thing that you can
point to and say hey man I love you this
many dollar
worth
oh oh oh oh it hurts I
know it hurts my
heart it hurts my
stomach hurts my
arms okay well why are you laying like
that
thanks how did you push away the bad
thoughts like what like maybe the real
reason they left was because there were
things they wanted you to do in bed that
were what foreign and scary I I don't
not that you didn't want to try
them some wine might have helped do you
know what I'm referring to oh well Oscar
you little G moront you have the next
turn I'll take
the teapot damn it okay moving along
Meredith let's go I really want the iPod
it's already been stolen this round pick
something else I hope nobody takes this
baby cuz this is great wow look at that
fine
craftsmanship going to really put a lot
of work into that it's beautiful I'll
take the oven
mitt sucker
a see I wanted somebody to take it boom
reverse psychology reverse psychology is
an awesome tool I don't know if you guys
know about it but basically you make
someone think the opposite of what you
believe and that tricks them into doing
something stupid works like a
charm like everybody's
attention Christmas is cancelled you
can't cancel a holiday give it up
Stanley and you will lose New Year years
what does that mean Jim take New Year
away from Stanley
Michael don't stop Dwight Dwight stop no
oh no stop oh no yes take my R like okay
seriously okay okay
yes I have a wig for every single person
in the
office you never know when you're going
to need to Bear a passing resemblance to
someone I just want it to
stop oh Jim hey hey Toby there's this
female uh scenographer at the courthouse
it looks exactly like you way that's
incredible yeah no it's uncanny you know
what's crazy I can't reconnect with you
right now hold on one
second
oh excuse
me it comes to 16641 uh right now you're
the expert is this enough to get 20
people
plastered 15 bottles of
vodka yeah I should do it cool cool box
it
up Phyllis I need you to pick up green
streamers at lunch I thought you said
green was
horish no orange is
horish and I'm here to remind you of the
mess you when you went away it's not
fair to deny me of the cross I bear that
you give to me you you you you you you
you ought to
know nice ready to
[Music]
go hey Meredith heading over to Poor
Richards yep cool cool cool you need a
ride
all right let's head
out sounds good do you have a coat yeah
okay what is that the committee to plan
parties invites you to a margarita
karaoke Christmas there's no such thing
as the committee to plan parties there
is now we just started it well you can't
just start a committee
you have to have funding what's your
funding $200 what's ours again um $201
right hey a margarita karaoke Christmas
party that sounds like fun no that is
not a party there's only one party and
it's hosted by the party planning
committee and it starts at 3:00 then why
are there two flyers I I understand that
this is confusing for everyone let me
explain there's a party that starts at
3:00 and then there's a way more fun
party that starts at
2:45 right and if you're interested in
the way more fun party all the info can
be found here on our more brightly
colored
flyer I didn't see where it was take a
bowl of pass it down thank you Dwight
These are nice no these are gift bowls
when you receive a gift it will go in
the bowl but the bowls must be returned
at the end they're a set now hold your
bowls
forward the Bel nickel will decide if
you are impish or admirable oh it's like
naughty or nice no impish or admirable
quick question do you just decide who
gets what in the moment or did you make
a list I decided earlier oh nice did you
check that list of course I checked it
but more than once cuz you could have
made mistake I checked it more than once
okay so you made a list you checked it
twice and now you're going to find out
who's impure admirable damn phis F cheer
of Fe Bel Nichol is here I judge your
year
as admirable
there you are H what are these it's a
set of rubber gaskets for canning jars
I'd rather have the bowl you can't have
the bowl Oscar Martinez cheer or fear
Bel snickel is here I judge your
year it's impish ow you hit people with
that thing no I'm carrying around the
stick in order to look cool for the
Kinder ooh mous trap in a head-to-head
contest people prefer for Bel schnickel
over Santa every time there aren't as
many songs about him but I attribute
that more to rhyming difficulties my
brother and I wrote one once it was
about a Fickle Pickle salesman who would
tickle you for a
nickel oh you know what I got to go St
giggling oh really already a punishment
hey where are you going I have to go to
Philly but this was amazing you work
tomorrow yeah I know I just like to
settle in and get a good night's sleep
but we were going to break the pig rib
oh remember that's
right no matter Bel nickel cares not
about this off with you perfect merry
Christmas everybody wait wait fit wait
don't you want to know your present you
know what yeah how about it Jim helpet
cheer of fear Bel schnickel is here I
judge your year as impish oh are you
nuts I judge you impish ow ow okay that
is three and you didn't hit anybody that
hard they're not abandoning the party
hey right that's enough I'm done
okay Bel schnickel I got to run out
early
too what is
this that is my Christmas card it's a
picture of you and me and your kids on a
ski trip having a blast ske's greetings
no see we never went on a ski trip I
know I know I went on a ski trip right
two years ago with my kids and my
ex-husband yes but what you didn't
realize at the time was that I was with
you in a sense I was in your heart and
next to your kids what this is so
weird hey Dwight pretty nice
rubs
why what is this happy holidays dway but
do not open it till Christmas you were
so pathetic how long did this take you 3
hours 5 minutes actually I am a black
belt in GI wrapping yeah no such thing
they don't give out black belts for
things that are
stupid well I hope it was worth it cuz
I'm going to take it apart in about 5
minutes I think I'll take you a little
bit longer than that really if I can
skin a mule deer in less than 10 minutes
I ought to be able to cut my
way Jam okay Jam you are
what what's what's
happening oh she's
asleep narcolepsy
probably okay now open your eyes and
describe it to
me uh I don't know it has four bedrooms
in The Loft oh my God now she's up yeah
and she's trying to describe how to
correctly butcher a goose but she's
having trouble coming up with it okay
Sydney go c
c hold its neck back insert the knife
beneath the jaw bring it all the way
around there's going to be a good amount
of blood don't let that bother you have
a bucket there for the blood and the
innards and the
feathers never this
garbage this is
[Applause]
[Music]
Christmas
n
[Music]
[Applause]
he
Yeah
Christmas you need to Yo game on on
it I don't know what I was thinking it
was awful Jessica did you just
fart and that is how it's
done hey sorry I'm ready
I don't want to go oh come on
bearan come
on have you ever seen them do
that I'm sorry I had no idea no it's
it's
okay okay oh my God oh my God no no no
no okay this is it what what this is
what this oh my
God
honey
J
in the end the greatest snowball isn't a
snowball at all it's
fear Merry
Christmas
that